today's questions from Dustin in Georgia
what are your thoughts on a Gerber baby
life insurance plan for our new baby be
$22 a month for $35,000 and that doubles
when he turns 18 is this a good
investment okay let's just say out loud
that you are discussing buying a
financial investment from a baby food
company let's just say out loud that you
just said that does that not make you
giggle just a little bit how stupid that
is I mean really you're going to buy an
investment from a baby food company it's
a whole life life-insurance policy on a
baby so let me help you with this Dustin
it's stupid really really stupid like
don't do it the money a little bit okay
let's try this let me just do this
twenty dollars put this in the
calculator because I just can't stand it
okay and eighteen years it was eighteen
right yep okay let's do this again
eighteen have been put on the calculator
here and let's see so okay if you were
to invest the twenty two dollars and a
decent growth stock mutual fund per
month from zero to 18 now let's go back
remember the Gerber whole life life
insurance ripoff baby plan from the baby
food company says if you put twenty two
dollars a month in you get thirty five
thousand dollars in life insurance and
it doubles when he turns 18 they didn't
say that you could cash it in for
seventy thousand they said you'd have
seventy thousand dollars worth of life
insurance which let me help you with
this that means you can have about a 10
or 12 thousand dollar cash value roughly
I'll be off a little bit but I won't be
off much
however if instead of getting ripped off
you were to put the twenty two dollars
and a decent growth stock mutual fund
for the same period of time you would
have not ten or twelve thousand not
$70,000 worth of
life insurance 125,000 dollars on
average with average mutual fund growth
rates interesting if I'm half wrong you
still came out wait I yeah so the answer
is never buy life insurance as an
investment let me say it again because
some of you get confused because you
miss the part where I said never never
buy life insurance as an investment the
math never works and never is like never
works and this little girl or policy is
an example that as a matter of fact is
one of it the math is even worse on it
than the typical ripoff adult whole life
policy I mean you can get ripped off by
Prudential you could get ripped off by
New York Life you could get ripped off
by Northwestern Mutual you could get bit
ripped off by a lot of these whole-life
companies if you want to and it you
wouldn't be ripped off as much as you
would by Gerber mathematically here now
you'd be putting more money in so you'd
lose more money but mathematically
percentage-wise
the twenty-two dollars will turn into
more than it would ever if you to put it
with other companies but it you know
sucks still sucks at the end of day it's
just a matter how bad something sucks
and this is all bad never use never use
life insurance as an investment vehicle
it never works for you it always comes
out better if you do your investing in
an investment oh yeah that's why they
call it that
and if you need life insurance just buy
some inexpensive life insurance that is
life insurance only like term life
insurance in other words and that's what
I have done or arty
something years and it's worked out for
me I'm a multi-millionaire and that's
one of the reasons I am because I didn't
give my money to these ripoff whole-life
companies and my babies were not insured
by Gerber life a baby food company
selling life insurance products really
right there should have been a hint okay
kind of sometimes if you're looking at
investment products or money things if
you look at where it's advertised and
what's advertised around it it will
sometimes tell you that you're not
supposed to do it I'll give you another
example let's pretend that your latest
financial thing you're wondering about
is advertised on television and the
advertisement running next to it is a
self-insert catheter or a walk-in
bathtub or a Snuggie that tells you that
the life insurance or that the financial
product being advertised is crap and so
let's think about who advertises right
next to walk-in bathtubs self-insert
catheters and Snuggies reverse mortgages
with the funds or magnum p.i yeah and
who else advertises there uh what's that
guy
what camera he played in a Mel Gibson
movie that was a really cool movie he
was the bad guy he got killed he was the
medium-level bad guy but he does the
gold coins thing you know with the bad
teeth guy you know it's got like caps on
his caps can't think of he's an actor
but he does the gold coins of it he does
the gold coins so gold coins is right in
there yeah it fits right in the mix here
um what else is ever ties there hmm Oh
we'll get you out of your income taxes
for free we will do get you out of your
you won't have to pay income taxes I can
show you how to go your income taxes for
free using now the IRS hounding you you
seen those ads one of the advertisers
right next to Snuggie
right next to self-insert catheter and
right next to the walk-in bathtubs so
that tells you right there the quality
of your financial products and you know
gerber life is right there in that same
bunch of people in the same neighborhood
no they're not advertising on the cable
TV but think about I mean what are they
doing it's a baby food company pulleys
please really I mean you buy your car
there too I mean I got a car I got a
Gerber live car I got a Gerber life blue
jeans
really I mean you just don't think of
them that way to you
and I don't think the baby foods bad but
maybe they should have stuck to that
here's the trick probably make more on
the life insurance it's really
profitable because it's crap oh it's
really profitable because it's crap so
here's the thing no we don't do Gerber
life life insurance we don't do any life
insurance that is an investment because
here's the deal one more time let's walk
through it $100 a month going out the
door for whole life life insurance for
those of you that are an adult now we
did twenty two dollars a month here and
show job that it wasn't going to go you
can buy the same amount of term life
insurance for about five dollars a month
that you can spend a hundred on for
whole life that means $95 is going into
the quote unquote investment side to
build up your cash value which has an
average rate of return with whole life
of 1.2 percent on universal life of 4.2%
and a variable life 7.3 percent after
fees these are outside studies that I'm
quoting that have absolutely nothing to
do with you and the life insurance
business now they tell you all kinds of
other rates but that's the actual after
fees rate of return that you can expect
and when you finally build up a cash
value because you put $95 out of every
hundred in there and you die do they pay
the face amount and pay the life
insurance amount what happened to your
savings account they keep it it's if
it's the payday lender or the
middle-class people it's a piece of
garbage
stay away from cash value life insurance
of any kind of investment life insurance
of any kind never use that as an
investment hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]